uh welcome back my friends now barely a
week passes without eco fanatics
sticking their noses into our morning
commute usually by sticking themselves
to bits of our roads today protesters
from just stop oil damaged fuel pumps
and glued themselves to a service
station forecourt along the m25 surrey
police tell us they've arrested at least
20 people yesterday the same group
caused chaos at old depots by staging
sit-down protests already this year
they've disrupted the bafta awards
that's not such a bad thing of the
british grand prix as well as sticking
themselves to various priceless works of
art joining me now is just stop all
protester alex de conning i hope that's
right and former top gear presenter
steve berry alex i don't have a go i
want to get straight to the point um i
have an issue with with this but i want
to ask you a question what does just
stop oil mean briefly
basically the government are trying to
push through another 40 new fossil fuel
facilities and we're demanding that
there should be no new oil licenses in
the uk because we have eight years in
reserve which is more than enough time
to have a fair transition to renewable
energy and to make sure the oil workers
are re-skilled and treated properly
right so here's what i'm going to say to
you how old are you i'm 24. i don't want
to sound like your dad but here's what
i'm going to say to you if you were 57
young man right and you had a family and
you had a mortgage and you had to go to
work and you had an energy crisis was
about to [ __ ] you financially would
you be sitting in a road or would you be
slightly hacked off if these eco zealots
or whatever you call them were making it
impossible for you to carry on with your
job i don't mean to be disrespectful in
any way i'm being honest every time i
get somebody from just stop oil they're
barely out of nappies no disrespect
where
why
you don't have any experience of the
real world it's just it's a bunch of
unwashed students giving it large you're
stopping people from doing going about
their daily lives man unwashed okay um
first of all we have many age ranges
i've been arrested next to people who
are
arrested
um
because this is the kind of action that
we need to take we're in a climate
emergency do you not realize how
important the situation yes i do but
you're not gonna like what i'm gonna say
and you're gonna say i'm gonna i don't
know what steve says we're in a climate
emergency there are people watching this
who cannot pay their bills they cannot
eat their houses they cannot feed their
kids and do you know what i'm going to
say to you yeah yeah the coffee leave
that a minute and concentrate what's no
i'm not saying to leave that a minute
the cost of living crisis is very
closely related to the climate crisis we
could be fixing both at the same time no
it could be insulating homes which saves
almost half on people's energy bills i'd
cut the green levy i'd cut v80 on fuel
and i pre i'm not saying energy bills
are 2.5 billion pounds higher than they
should be
green policies have been scrapped over
the last decade here's another we
subsidize public transport which we were
talking about before we arrived on the
show that would save people a fortune on
transportation costs as well as i'm not
disagreeing about the fact that there
are issues i'm talking about how you do
it and now bringing steve briefly really
appreciate what you're saying
do we i think it'd be great to be that
young and idealistic i was like that
when i was his age combat jacket placard
band the bomb down with this sort of
thing vegetable rights and peace but
it's not patronizing what i'm saying
you're right but you're entitled to this
opinion but you are
there seem to be two there seem to be
two groups there's there's nice well
presented well spoken yeah there is
middle class young people like that and
then there's
people in their 50s and 60s who look
like they went to the public sector
retired early on a board watching
antiques road trip and tipping point so
they want something to do
they're asking for stop oil oil is
stopping but there's going to be
but there's going to be a transitional
period look at the population the
transitional people should start right
now look we have eight years ago it was
40 degrees in london a few weeks ago 40
degrees it was that in 1976 but you
weren't around to experience it
do you want to see the grass i can show
you the grass can i say can i just jump
in just generally for one reason and i
and i've said my piece and fair place
you've said yours do you not think
there's a more constructive way and i go
back to it and i never get answered this
than ruining what you what you do is you
stick yourselves to these things and you
make it impossible for people to get all
the lives why are you not talking sense
as you've actually spoken hands in the
air i've learned more from you in two
minutes than all of those dullards
sticking themselves to whatever and
making our lives more difficult that's
the point i'm making but sadly we would
not get on shows like these if it wasn't
for stuff like this i'd have you on
you'd have to stick yourself to anything
i'm waiting for that hand move that hand
oh it's fine we're all right
instead of inconveniencing hard-working
people as they try and get to work or
school or wherever they've got to go why
don't they glue themselves to the yachts
of these super rich
guys that are making all this money
which says
why don't you do that and i'd say well
i'll tell you why because they might
have to go outside the uk and then they
find the sort of policing where they
don't ask for your pronouns first they
give you a crack with a stick which is
virtually everywhere else inside the uk
look what happened in italy when they
tried pulling this sort of routine
people not the police just got out of
the car
and dragged them out
i will never forget that woman right in
the the range rover i couldn't get to
the hospital with the guy i'm just
asking you alex i'm not you can't take
stuff
do you understand her frustration with
you and your friends of course i
understand so why don't you do it
differently why are you not getting the
people on the show who have been
disrupted because train tracks have
spontaneously combusted because heathrow
runways have been melted so flights
couldn't take off and flash floods so
people couldn't get to work in that way
why haven't you got people on the show
who because i've only got two minutes
left and i've got you on
no but you're always focusing on this
kind of disruption and not the other
kinds of things because
well you say we're focusing on
disruption my friend that's because you
and your supporters and the only way to
stop us and also to stop the other kinds
of disruption from the climate crisis is
for the government to stop issuing new
fossil fuels so you won't stop doing
what you're doing until the government
does that is that what you're saying
exactly that's what i'm saying
is why would we stop final word you
always do it in the south east of
england come to salford try it up there
see how you get online you you got
arrested in newcastle my favorite city
you were left shaking after being
forcibly dragged away yeah so we were
very surprised by the response i'm doing
my phd in green hydrogen production at
newcastle university and i just want to
point out that there are so many
solutions that i found through this that
it was not being used we have these well
i'll tell you what come back on the show
right come back on the show and spend
time talking to me about that but i will
never change and i mean that genuinely
because fair play to you but my my issue
is is that
is the disruption the disrespect i'm not
listen you might have a very good point
but i think you have to understand that
people are really struggling and i think
that right now right now
they don't look kindly i'm saying if you
want traction from your
i'm arguments trying to win the x factor
here it's not a popularity contest we
are doing this because we need things to
change fair enough history has shown
that in order to get the kind of radical
change that we need at the time scale we
have this is the solution women did not
get the vote by voting on it no they
threw themselves in front of a horse
final word from you steve berry
wrong target target these rich fat cats
dot not working people
really really appreciate and that is an
open offer and i mean that man to man
absolutely thank you very much very much
for having us steve thank you alex